>> Hello YouTube. I'm Ann Cotton. I'm a [inaudible]
entrepeneur here at Davos, the World Economic
Forum. There's a big economic issue being
discussed here which is really about exclusion
of women and girls for so many opportunities
and of course the likelihood of economic downturns.
That situation will actually get worse. So
we will undermine the real opportunity that
exists for change. My work is in Africa. I
lead an orgainization camp there, The Campaign
for Female Education that is supporting education,
leadership and enterprise of young girls and
women. And I came to Davos via Zambia in fact.
This time last week I was in a village down
there and they certainly not heard of the
national economic crisis, but they will feel
it, there's no doubt about that. There was
a report published by the World Bank in 2007
that showed that in the time between 1980
to 2004 and over other economic downturns,
that over one million babies died which otherwise
would have survived, and that's the reality.
It's a crisis of immense proportions. Not
only that, but what would also happen is that
girls would leave school prematurely. There
are currently 600 million children outside
education, 75% of them girls. And if they
do leave school, age 10, 11 and 12, they will
marry young. They will start having babies
when they are very young and their babies
will be born into poverty. The whole inter-generative
cycle of poverty will start all over again
and that will resonate down through the years.
That's an issue for all of us. An issue for
the global economic community. Because of
course, it effects everything, it effects
population growth, it effects the environment,
it effects child health and child mortality.
So there's a real opportunity to address this.
To recognize the enormous impact that the
crisis will have on the poorest of nations
and on the poorest in those nations. If you
take a look at conference website www.amfa.org
and get involved, and change and support the
opportunities that we must create for everybody
in the world. Thanks.